un très beau spécimen de cette variété
de rongeurs nous accueille ce matin
juste à l'entrée de l'école primaire les
jackets à fond saint jacques à sainte
marie une présence qui prouve bien que
les parents d'élèves très soucieux de la
sécurité de l'hygiène de ces
établissements qui accueillent les
enfants avaient bien raison de se
mobiliser aujourd'hui et dresse un état
des lieux en compagnie des membres du
service technique et de la direction
s'il constate que nettoyage a
effectivement été réalisés durant les
deux jours de fermeture aisée mais tout
de même quelques réserves
vérifie si le grand nettoyage a été fait
on constate que le nettoyage classique a
été fait oui mais pas de grands grands
nettoyages puisque toujours la poussière
sur les tables on constate quand même
qui a pas de crotte de rats dans la
classe
mais voilà le grand grand nettoyage n'a
pas été fait le dit il n'y a pas de
souci on a travaillé tout le week end on
l'a travaillé depuis mercredi j'ai eu
une autre date le jeudi vendredi et le
dit on parce qu'à ses heures
je pense que le passé si à l'issue de
cette réunion de concertation
il dresse un premier bilan de la
situation au vu du constat
donc nous nous rendons compte quand même
qu'il y ait un effort de fait puisque
l'entretien donc deux aux abords de
l'établissement
donc
a été fait des pièges ont été posées
toutefois nous nous rendons compte que
certains ont été retrouvés donc sans les
a pas donc ce que nous demandons donc à
la municipalité
c'est d'effectuer donc c'est suivi donc
réguliers sur cet établissement puisque
ça prouve que les rongeurs se sont
encore présents donc il est nécessaire
de mettre toutes les conditions va dire
d'hygiène et de et de sécurité un
nouveau concert est prévu donc 2h du
matin avant la reprise des cours ils ont
pu constater le nettoyage qui a été fait
un second nettoyage sera fait demain
matin avant l'arrivée des enfants donc
un sur nettoyage pour que les enfants
pour être assurés que les enfants soient
dans la salle de classe en toute
sécurité
outre la réouverture l'établissement dès
lundi matin
un nettoyage permanent des lieux
s'impose afin d'éviter toute présence de
rongeurs et autres nuisibles
car cette petite école et chaque et
situées en milieu rural est aujourd'hui
cerné par plusieurs résidences mais
aussi se trouve à proximité d'une
rivière